welcome everyone thank you for joining
us for today's webinar
developing precision combination
therapies to overcome evolution of
therapeutic resistance presented by dr.
Ciotti Shaw
post doctoral research scholar at
University of California San Francisco
my name is executors and I will be your
moderator for today's event we're
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by lab roots lab
roots is the leading scientific social
networking website and producer of
educational virtual events and webinars
before we begin I would like to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you look
during the presentation simply click on
the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen and type your
questions into the drop-down box our
speaker will respond to your questions
via email following the presentation if
you have trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please click on the ask a
question box to let us know that you're
experiencing a problem this presentation
is educational and best offers
continuing education credits please
click on the continuing education
credits tab located in the top right
corner of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits now without further ado please
join me in welcoming dr. Shah I will now
turn the presentation over to her Thank
You Xavier and thank your lab for giving
me this opportunity for presenting my
world so since this is our drug
discovery symposium I'm going to talk
about how we can develop the precision
combination therapy and how that can
help overcome the therapeutic resistance
and to get started I will just give the
outline of my talk so in first I will
introduce wide the chalk resistance is
prevalent problem in drug discovery what
are the strategies by which we can
overcome the therapeutic resistance and
over the off drug combination to enhance
drug discovery and as an example of
designing the rationale drug combination
I will give an example how therapeutic
resistance to EJ
TK I can be targeted utilizes
combination and develop further strategy
so to do that I will talk about my model
systems that we developed to model the
acquired resistance and how we can use
the high content microscopy to discover
the combination therapy I will also talk
about our desserts that we identified
our kinase a as a synthetic synthetic
lethal target to overcome resistance and
at the end I will give my conclusion so
let's get started with this so just to
give you the current landscape of drug
discovery as you can see from here 1993
to 2018 there is increasing increase in
amount of new molecule entity or
biological entity that has been filed to
FDA for drug approval and 2018 was the
highest where we saw for 14 new drug
application and 17 biological
applications for drug approval and
that's a huge if you overall look at the
trend of drug discovery especially in
case of oncology oncology saw highest
amount of drug approval or the drugs
that enter into the clinical trial
however there are so many molecules that
enter the clinical trial but not all of
them succeed and the reason being there
is a high attrition rate meaning that
the drug that entered a clinical chart
our clinical trial doesn't get a few and
that attrition rate is highest in
oncology
there are various reason behind this
high attrition rate a there is a
limitation of efficacy be there could be
chocolaty that is not discovered in
preclinical target lack of efficacy lack
of a biomarker lack of a lack of knowing
the right population to target the
trough and hence barrier for various
reasons the drug discovery has seen the
small amount
success in terms of getting drug
approved so what can we do about it we
are getting better at this
so now in the case of a post genomic era
we can classify the tumor based on its
antigenic genetic driver and in case of
a non small cell lung cancer it is a
step in case of announcement cell lung
cancer you can see that based on the
genomic driver tumor can be classified
and there are major drivers such as
Kara's EGFR activation activating
mutations that happen that drives the
oncogenesis of non-small cell lung
cancer and I will focus for this purpose
on only on EGFR so EGFR is known as a
epoch epithelial growth factor receptor
and it tries to cell proliferation in
non-small-cell lung cancer so there are
various inhibitors that are designed to
prevent this hyperactivity of EGFR and
some example of these EGFR TK eyes are a
lot in it a pattern em and recently most
recently you see more than em so just to
give you an example of posa Martinov
progression in the clinic awesome RT
they passed first synthesized in 2009
and in 2013 it entered clinical trials
this is a very unconventional way of
getting into the drug trial in a very
short amount of time but this truck was
highly efficacious and when it entered
into the clinical trial in the phase 1
phase 1 itself there was a demonstration
of efficacy and US fda approved this in
the in the patient subset of patient
with non small cell lung cancer who have
resistance mutations in t7 IDM and hence
the drug got fast-tracked of in 2014 and
then in 2016 it was approved as a
first-line therapy for patients with
EGFR mutations and overall if you see
the total cost of drugs
Luckman for Olsen Martinez was about 2.6
billion dollars and currently the annual
sale of this drug is 1.75 1.7 billion
dollars and it's expected to rise by 10
billion in 2025 so there is a huge
success benefit available to the patient
who have harbored this EGFR mutations in
them however if you look at the
waterfall curves of these patient so
what are waterfall curves for four cows
over here indicates the response of the
patient to that particular therapy and
each bar over here is an individual
patient so what you can see that the
majority of the patient have either
unconfirmed partial response or they
were standard disease that they
progressed on very few patient
eventually receive complete response so
a this response is not durable and B
there is never a complete response
meaning that this therapy although is
very successful has a has a major
limitation in terms of acquired
resistance does this happen in the other
cancer and the answer is yes what you
can see here in the picture is the
patient with the melanoma when they were
putting a beer as they Harbor birra
v600e mutations and when you can when
you see that when the patient before the
therapy in a was on at the time of
diagnosis when the patient was put on
the melanoma when we're after net
therapy in 15 weeks a patient saw like
regression of the tumor and almost
normal-looking morphology over here but
the patient on therapy progressed within
seven weeks in such a short amount of
time with even more aggressive tumors so
it's clear that the resistance is a
major bottleneck of any success of the
therapy recently there is a lot of
excitement with the approval of
immunotherapy and
resistance is prevalence in the case of
immunotherapy also so here is the
example of anti ctla-4 majority of the
patient despite having the CT LF for a
marker they do not respond to the
therapy well what you can see on the
left side of the panel and in the case
of the right side of the panel the
patient there are subsets of the patient
who respond but they almost never
receive the complete benefit or complete
cure out of this therapy PDL one also
has a similar trend meaning that the
majority of the patient who respond aid
do not achieve the long-lasting benefit
and B there is emergence of resistance
in for the therapy so just to give you
the flavor that most of the patient with
advanced cancer died because of the
cancer exists exhibits or develops a
resistance to the therapy that they are
taking and hence that I paradigm
shifting efforts are needed to
understand and combat the resistance and
to discover the mechanisms that is
underlying the resistance so therapeutic
resistance can be mainly classified as a
primary resistance or a quad resistance
in case of a primary resistance these
are the patient who were on the left
side of the waterfall called meaning
that they do not show any benefit from
initial drug therapy despite having the
positive markers for it and these
patients would have like a tumor
intrinsic factor and activation of
alternative pathways downstream or there
could be a patient specific factor
meaning that the patient have either
drug drug interactions or are
metabolizing the trunk very fast and
hence the drug is not available for the
activity however majority of the patient
do respond initially but how did have a
incomplete response and the factors that
causes this incomplete response and
eventually progression consists of a
makes it
to the acquired resistance and acquired
resistance who displayed in a full
flavor that could be the target
modifications so the drug that we are
trying to target could could modify and
exhibit like a secondary side mutations
causing the inactivation of drug binding
pocket there could be a bypass signaling
meaning that there could be a
compensatory you that can be activated
and hence this pathway is hyperactive
and is the drug has no efficacy in that
case there could be an example of
histological transformation meaning that
the patient tumor completely transformed
into a new phenotype but there could be
the other mechanisms such as increase in
the growth factor productions so now
that I have given you the flavors of
what kind of therapeutic resistance
mechanisms are seen in the clinic there
has to be a strategy to overcome this so
first I will focus on the primary
resistance so the patient when they
display the tumor intrinsic factors
there could be the tumor intrinsic
factor can also be targeted by newer
target low blockade and mostly this is
achieved by drug combination if there
are patient specific factors then we
need to modify the dose or modify the
schedule how the patient is receiving
the drug in case of her acquired
resistance whether it is target
modifications or patients can try the
next generation EGFR inhibitor next
generation in inhibitors such as in case
of EGFR if the patient progresses on or
not in it they take OSA motive which is
which is efficacious in inhibiting this
target modification of t7 I am so
clearly the drug combination works in
such patients if there is a bypass
signaling then again the newer target
block that is needed for the pathway
that is alternatively activated upon
therapy and to target that also we use
truck combination if there is a
histological transformation
we need to identify what what change
according this tumor and how this tumor
has developed the synthetic lethality in
there and that can also be targeted with
a drug combination so clearly this
suggests that for the targeted therapy
the drug combination works the best in
order to inhibit the resistance so the
question is does this happen only in
resistance happens only in targeted
therapy or it happens in MMO oncology
and the answer is it can happen to women
on hook hair critics as well if you look
at the common mechanism resistance
mechanisms in case of all immuno on
pathetic mutants it's mainly are the
primary resistance meaning that the
patient samples have tor
infiltration of the immune component
that could be acquired resistance caused
by loss of the antigen presentation on
them on there could be the resistance
because of the alterations of chemokines
that could be over expression of wedges
that could lead to alter t-cell
trafficking into the tumor formation
there are various factors also that
would be like a modulation of hoe
stimulatory pathway that upon PDL one
inhibition that could lead to the
primary resistance and there are various
mutations in check one check two pathway
or app regulation of PDL 1 or app
regulation of other immune checkpoint
markers that causes the third resistance
to to the immunotherapy and hence to do
that to counteract this therapeutic
resistance to even on the therapeutics
people have tried various combinations
therapy to target the various modalities
of the immune component such as myeloid
component can be targeted with the idea
inhibitor or a NTC v40 inhibitor the G
factor cells can be modulated by the
combination of either PDL 1 ctla4
inhibition or anti lagg-3
antibodies the t-rex can also be
modified and the tumour intrinsic
factors can be modified with the help of
combination therapy targeted therapy or
chemotherapy so clearly the combination
therapy exerts lot of benefit in order
to overcome the quad resistance to
targeted therapy and to immunotherapy so
is this resistance mechanism and that
combination is the story historically
very well known and what you can see
over here that in the history of the of
the drug development initially people
have identified the methods by which you
can you can find out whether the drug
has a synergistic effect or whether the
drug is the additive effect and to me in
terms of drug discovery when the BCR
Abel was discovered there were the
resistance mechanisms that were also
double identified with it and as you can
see in the path pathway of drug
discovery at various stages the apart
resistance as well as the complementary
targeted drug combination has been
discovered and the advantages of it what
you can see over here so what I have
shown you earlier is that the patients
do not respond to the single agent
immunotherapy very well but in this case
when you combine the anti ctla4 and MVPD
on one inhibitor you can see that these
patients not only have derived like a
better benefit of it but maturity of the
patient responds showing that most of
the patient fall on the right side of
the curve the left side of the curve so
the combination therapy has a lot of
advantage to it in case of a targeted
therapy these are the patient melanoma
patient that I showed you earlier in the
picture that were progressing but now
when they take a combination of the VRP
inhibitor such as camera
and map kinase inhibitor which is the
alternate pathway that is activated or
the pic almost all the patients do
respond initially to to the to the
combination of very well and hence it's
being shown in the field that the
chemotherapy and targeted therapy or
both the immunotherapy by itself have do
not have a strong capability to induce
complete response but the combination of
shown over here's of aluminum and pd1
blockade can enhance the response but
now that we know what will be the other
path or the resistance mechanism so we
can design like a suitable trip by
combination along with the targeted
therapy or with the chemotherapy to
drive to enhance the survival benefit of
this drug and to do that there are
currently two about 2250 active clinical
trials going on along with the different
different immunotherapy on x axis and on
biases you can see the different
modalities on that can be combined with
this too to maximize the drug response
so why we do this on the reason because
we can enhance the efficacy of the drug
and hence it can have a a patient
beneficent survival benefit as well as
that could there should it can increase
the profitability of the pharmaceutical
industry and hence there is a lot of
investment by pharmaceutical companies
to to discover this combination and
study the resistance mechanisms so now
that I have given you the background of
why drug resistance is a bigger problem
and why combination can potentially
overcome this I would give going to the
more specific example with the case of
EGFR t ki so over here you can see the
patient at the time of diagnosis at the
baseline have a tumor burden it in that
when the patient
streeted will be a CD 1991 which is the
ocean Martinov which is a EGFR TBI
patient shows maximal response and there
is only a residual disease very Chinese
humour left in the middle panel but when
the patient was capped on the awesome
metallic video or 10 to 12 months they
developed the acquire resistance and now
that in in the presence of drug that
tumor were actively proliferating and
this resistance mechanisms are a very
well-known in case of the EGFR gki so
what you can see over here that the
resistance mechanisms to
first-generation EGFR inhibitors are met
amplification hard to amplification XL
upregulation that could be mutations and
pi3 kinase and beat mira pathway that
could be EMT epithelial to mesenchymal
transformation as well as small cell
looking morphology on these patients
receive third-generation EGFR inhibitor
on such as awesome metallic peak sample
that I've shown but the patient also
relapse to that with either the known
genetic mechanisms or with unknown
genetic mechanisms and these patient
have no effective Salvage therapies
available to them meaning that if you
are a patient on EGFR TTI and if you
progress upon the third-generation EGFR
inhibitor you say Morton L there is no
option for you other than chemo and
these tumors are immune or refractory
meaning that think there is no other
option so how the resistance is modeled
if monitored in the clinic it's mainly
monitored with the liquid biopsy so the
patient who initially when diagnosed
with the EGFR activating mutations on
they take the blood sample and do the
liquid biopsy to see what is the
prevalence of EGFR mutations once a
patient progresses on the first
generation EGFR inhibitor as you can see
that there is a steady increase in the
EGFR
gisun IBM which is the resistance clone
and and the intermediate stab this
resistance mechanism is prevalent and
these patients are get put on to the
concentration EGFR inhibitor and once
they progress on third-generation EGFR
inhibitor you can see that mutations
profile on the chip p53 mutation logos
are there is a emergence of the
secondary mutations in each afrc 797 s
also getting up so this tumor is
constantly evolving upon the progression
of the therapy and the tumor evolution
is a driving force of clonal
diversification these readouts that we
measure in the liquid biopsy comes from
the different clones that are present in
the tumors and how these clone
diversification initiates it's not known
and what are the strategy to prevent the
evolution is also unknown it's being
thought that since we see the various
varieties of the clones on which evolved
over a period of time we can target
multiple you but these resistance
mechanism often happens in the same
tumor in same tumor and you cannot
design poly therapy to target like five
different clones it's not favorable in
terms of patient a in terms of cost and
B in terms of toxicity so what are the
ways to inhibit this clonal
diversification and human evolution we
wanted to study this and to study this
field developing a clinical equivalence
model clinical equivalence model to
study this EGFR tki resistant so
initially when the tumor is sensitive um
you give them the EGFR t ki and in vitro
most of the cells die so you can see the
steep decline from day 0 to day 3 upon
the EGFR therapy what happens in the
patient but eventually is upon maximal
response there are sound drop tolerant
cells that are left in the patient tumor
and this give rise to a residual disease
and ultimate
these residual disease eventually
progress and display in terms of
acquired resistance so we can clearly
model this in vitro here you can see the
cells enters the residual or trucked
ordered phase and at the end of between
three to nine days and after when you
keep them on drug after six weeks these
cells start proliferating again in
presence of drug and to study this we
took like four drug sensitive cell line
treated with the awesome water them to
this to develop the upward resistance
aligns and here I am just giving an
example of truce two models so the PC
nine and nineteen seventy five are the
parent role cells indicated here in
green and they are sensitive to the two
different third-generation EGFR
inhibitor but when you take the acquired
resistance cells the they are they can
tolerate the high amount of drug and did
grow fine in presence of job so since we
saw the benefit of studying the drug
combination I'm just giving a practical
considerations that we can take into
account to identify what are the
combinations that get and how we can
design the combinations so the basic
methodology to study the synergistic
action is to do the drug response matrix
where you take that to draw and you ask
the combined inhibition and then you
calculate the combination index using
following methods in a high-throughput
screening way or you can have a refine
genetic or a pharmacological perturb
systems where you study the drug drug
interactions or drug gene interactions
or gene-gene interactions using either
can a library protract inhibitors or RNA
I library or CRISPR but the point of
these therapy is to identify the
synthetic lethality or a dependency that
has been altered in the in the cells and
once you identify these combinations or
a genetic dependency or more genetic
dependency for that matter
we need to validate that and to validate
that we primary use either these cells
ex-vivo
in cell culture or we use P DX or
xenograft or organoid models to verify
the synergistic effect of the
combination so there are different types
of combinations first is a synergistic
or additive combination how that have an
effect of draw on drug resistance is
either they can prevent the pathway
reactivation or it can prevent the
downstream pathway inhibition or it can
cause the inhibition of parallel or
compensatory pathways with the help of
RNA AI or CRISPR you can detect the
synthetic lethality to identify the
genetic dependency or there could be
these combinations can help you to
reverse the resistance and I'm going to
talk more about about the reversal of
resistance and how to overcome the
pathway bypass to restore sensitivity so
I just I told you that we develop this
acquire resistant model so now we take
our parents was 1975 sensitive cell line
and we take the 1975 acquired resistance
cell line and we perform the
high-throughput screening to identify
the combination that have a maximum
using a high content microscopy that can
induce the maximum synergy in the cells
and we basically create this composite
of composite matrix where we can
identify the drugs that have highest
energy score meaning that the drug can
induce the combination can induce
maximum killing in compared to the both
the monotherapy
so we perform this truck screen or in
the acquired resistant cells and we
identify the ad term other kinase
inhibitor for the top two synergizing
agent in acquired resistance cells along
with the EGFR inhibitor so when we
validate this further using our ex vivo
model
what you can see over here is that the
two Akbar resistant cell lines were
completely insensitive to the EGFR
inhibitor as well as three different or
economies in the picture but you can see
in the panel of combination when we
combine the EGFR as well as the ARRA
kinase inhibitor you see the maximum
synergy in them and when you when you
make a xenograft of these model and when
you when you treat the tumor you can see
that the combination reduces the cell
growth tumor growth in a profound manner
as compared to both the monotherapy
meaning that the combination works
effectively but the question still
remains why do we see the synergy with
the ORA kinase inhibitor what
potentially our kinase pathway can do so
to understand that more I will talk
about the ARRA Heinie's biology a little
bit
so our kinase consists of three
different family
Aurora pennies a B and C are a kinase a
is mainly located in the spindle poles
and Arakanese B is mainly located on the
chromosomal essential complex as you can
see our kinase be in a green and our
Heinie's a on the spindle pole in red
hello
our our kinase a is involved in
regulating the survival during my top
mitotic delay and errors and our kinase
is mainly regulated by a upstream
activator elastic allosteric activator
called TP x2 when gbx2 binds to the
Arakanese
it enhances its auto phosphorylation and
it provides the phosphatase from binding
to this or a kinase meaning keeping it
in a highly active form so why why we
see this Aerith Heinie's dependency and
what does all right chick aurora a and
gbx2
does in case of EGFR so as as as you can
see we went back to our models of the
sensitive models and the resistance
model inbred and sensitive models in
and you can see that amongst four
different resistant model as compared to
the parenthood cells in green
Her Highness is highly phosphorylated
highly activated and its upstream
co-activator is also highly up regulated
in this a part of the stem cells so now
if we change this acquired will if we
take this the parent one cells and
overexpress them with TP x2 and phosphor
aura do we see increase in the cell
lumbar and the answer is yes what you
can see over here in the panel is that
without a kinase a overexpression and
without gtx to overexpression b-cells
are able to only 20% of the cells are
able to survive in presence of EGFR tki
but when you give them the Rakhine ease
80px two or more resistance causing gene
such as chaos is able to cause a
decrease sensitivity to the drug meaning
that our chinese a over expression or
activation prevents these cells from
drug-induced cell death and also when we
probe this kinase activation more
closely in the acquired resistance cells
it's it's known that our chinese causes
the genomic heterogeneity and as you can
see that these EGFR tki treated cells
display higher amount of genomic
heterogeneity in terms of their
chromosomes are highly unstable their
microtubules are completely messed up
and when you quantify them they have
like higher from one centrosome under
that they have a very messed up spindle
geometry and there is a lot of errors in
the chromosome segregation but these
cells are able to survive and ultimately
proliferate and forms the basis of the
of the upward resistance and these cells
display high genomic heterogeneity and
this genomic heterogeneity is equivalent
to what happens when you have the high
GPA it's two and Arakanese in so
geniusly express so what you can
you over here is that when you
overexpress the Iraqis a and GPX - in in
the sensitive salons you see that the
number of defects that these cells
Harman goes up meaning that Aurora a and
GPX to itself can induce genomic
heterogeneity so now the answer is very
clear that the Arak kinase a and gbx2
can cause this genomic heterogeneity in
the cells they prevent he cell death and
so they are the one that give rise to
the of the other pathway that are
responsible for the survival and if we
go back to what clinical equal to model
of resistance what we see that in in the
case when you look at the array kinase
activation over a period of time we see
that our kinase and GP x2 is highly up
regulator upon in from the late
sensitive to resin your model and it's
required in the upward resistance model
this not only happens in case of a
third-generation EGFR inhibitor but it
happens in the first generation second
generation as well as third generation
EGFR inhibitor and in terms of what it
can do to prevent the combination can be
effective in terms of preventing the
resistance so here you can see that PC 9
which is the sensitive cells when you
give them the both the mono therapy
order Chinese alone that there is no
abyssion of cell growth but when you
give them the EGFR therapy the cell one
in the orange and one in the green you
can see that the cells initially undergo
apoptosis and there are very minimal
cells left by the end of the file but
then these cells are able to form the
residual disease and eventually by the
day of 20 and update 20 they start
proliferating again but if you combine
this EGFR and Erica is in a better one
in black and one in pink you can see
that there is no
emergence of the resistance meaning that
these combinations are potent to induce
the higher magnitude of cell growth
inhibition and when you take the
residual cells meaning that the cells
that initially survive the EGFR cheekier
therapy one in green and one in blue
they they can form this residual disease
but then you could read them with the
combination with a kinase inhibitor
increase in pink and in red you see that
there is a regression of this residual
disease so finally how it can induce the
what what is the general what is the
dependency that is created by the
activation of our kinase pathway in VEGF
our cells so what we noticed over here
is that when you treat them treat the
cells with the yo Pro menu when you
treat the cells with the EGFR gki in the
sensitive cells they induce apoptosis
but in the case of acquired resistance
cells both Amano therapy in the red does
not induce apoptosis but when you
combine that to be mln it 8 2 3 7 which
is the kinase inhibitor one in the last
panel in in blue as well as in the red
you see that there is a maximum increase
in the apoptosis indicated by a high
positive cells so these cells induced
higher combination induces the higher
magnitude of apoptosis in these cells
and to study that we went to look at the
molecular activity that is going on in
these cells so these cells as you can
clearly see that um in the case of
parental cells as well as in the
acquired resistance RC phospho EGFR is
not activated meaning that there is no
pathway reactivation you can see that
the era kinase is inhibited only in the
case of combination so plus over here
indicates the addition
or economies inhibitor you can see that
only in the case of combination in the
acquired resistance as the bill which is
the blow-up optic module of the search
is stabilized meaning that only the
combination is abundant important
apoptosis in these cells and hence we
know that the EGFR as well as our kinase
pathway converges into the regulating
the beam stability and how these cells
do that is by creating a dependency so
when you have the treatment naive cells
in case of EGFR are same pretreated
you can see that the bim is destabilized
and these cells are able to survive but
when you give them the mono therapy of
EGFR tki now beam is able to stabilize
and these cells undergo apoptosis
however there are some residual cells
that have higher aurora Heinie's and
they can also destabilize them and these
cells are able to survive but only when
you combine the two pathways of EGFR
inhibition as well as error caused
Arakanese inhibition then the bill is
now stabilized and you see the apoptosis
in them so meaning that the rational
design of the combination therapy is
required for the complete inhibition of
the cell proliferation and upward
resistance so what I have told you so
far is the strategy how the how the
resistance is a prevalent problem and
how it happens in the case of for each
of our tki cells so when you take the
Parenthood cells which are each a EGFR
tki sensitive and you give them the EGFR
t ki there is a formation of drug
tolerance cells and these short tolerant
cells ultimately from the acquired
resistance cells what we saw is that in
these cells the GP x 2 and Arakanese
excess is upregulated and ultimately
these cells acquire additional
alterations because they are highly
genomic instead in stable then a by 2
select this multiple genomic driver and
undergoes something called alteration
selections and display various genetic
mechanisms that we see in the clinic
such as T 790 m or C 797 s which is the
EGFR pathway activating mutations or the
other
EGFR independent genetic mechanisms such
as met amplification how to
amplification FGFR amplification or pi3
kinase mutations this is what we usually
measure in the clinic um so we think
that the combination of EGFR and
Arakanese inhibitor can prevent this
formation of drug-tolerant cells it can
prove when you target them at our
residual disease you can prevent
deformation of the acquire resistant
cells and ultimately the genetic
resistance that we see in the clinic so
are our combinations such a strongly
suggest the hypothesis that we can
prevent the evolution of resistance by
upfront targeting the EGFR and our high
knees signaling so to summarize I told
you that the drug combination serve as a
versatile truth to address the
limitations of therapeutic resistance
the rationale combination design can
reveal the underpinning of the bypass
mechanisms and in the case of EGFR gki
before we found that the activation of
Aurora is associated with the resistance
and inactivation of our kinase can serve
as a synthetic lethal target to enhance
the response of EGFR GI and the option
combination of EGFR tki along with the
arrow kinase inhibitor can serve as an
anti evolution approach to limit the
evolution of resistance that we see so
now I want to give you the I want to
leave you with the future direction and
how we can design the combination
therapy so in the past our pathologists
would look at the cancer samples and
design design what would be the drug
target for the patient in case of one in
case of the modern Juma
era we rely highly on the protein
expression mRNA expression or single
gene amplification such as what is the
genomic driver but in future we will be
able to do the deep profiling and
identify what are the different genomic
drivers or proteomic drivers that are
present and drives this and that can
inform the rational design of
combination therapy currently we perform
the the drug combination design was just
based on the hypothesis or just based on
the model of calculating the combination
index but with the advent of precision
oncology and with the decreasing cost of
NGS methods we can generate this
knowledge based evolutionary system
based model to identify what are the
pathways regulations and what it means
in terms of therapy initially we relied
just on the chemotherapy but now with
the advent of present technology we know
what are the genomic drivers and we can
combine that knowledge to design the
efficacious combination in the past the
drug resistance was only based on the
flux transporters that are present on
the cell surface which will limit the
efficacy of the drug but now we know how
to classify the patients according to
their genomic underpinning and hopefully
that can help us to design the vector
combination in terms of it there is a
resistance mechanisms that are present
and hopefully that would be able to
design a adaptive clinical trials that
will click classify patient based on
their genomic driver of the resistance
and allow the patient to undergo the
combination therapy so that's the vision
for the future but there are limitation
to this combination therapy meaning that
there are various challenges in terms of
evaluating the combination the target
validity and engage the target
engagement need to be validated the
pharmacological effects of combining
both the both the therapy modality needs
to be
validating how do we select the patient
who will derive the maximum benefit from
the a combination is unknown there is
sunshine pathway overlapping toxicity
that is that will limit the use of the
combination um we need to design the
optimal dose and reducing schedule we
need to identify biomarker of response
of the patient who will respond to this
one combination therapy and what would
be the resistant mechanisms to the
combination therapy is need to be
investigated so that's the future
directions how we can utilize the
combination in drug discovery so good
with that I would like to say thank you
all I would like to thank my lab numbers
at UCSF and previous collaborator who
makes this is a such exciting work
environment and my funding agencies
thank you all a part of this work was
published in Nature Medicine so please
side on what um and let me know if you
have any questions thank you so much
thank you dr. Shah for that informative
presentation I'd also like to thank lab
roots for making today's educational
webcast possible before we go I want to
let everyone know that this webcast will
be available for on-demand viewing
through May of 2019 and as a final
reminder our speaker will follow up with
any of your questions you've submitted
via email that's all for now thank you
for joining us and we hope to see you
again soon goodbye